Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna take a look at my
favorite SaaS and open source integration framework,
Pipedream.
But before we do that, I need to
say thank you to my employer, Equinix Medal.
Equinix Medal is a bare metal cloud,
and they give me the time and the
resources to invest in this show and produce
content so that we can all learn together.
If you wanna check out Equinix Medal, you
can visit medal.equinix.com,
and you can use the code Rawkode dash
live. This will give you $50 in credit.
That $50 can get you around one hundred
hours of compute on our smallest instance, but
it's much more fun to get the bigger
instances and spend it a little bit quicker.
So check it out and let me know
how you get up.
Now, today, I am joined by the cofounder
and engineer at Pipedream, Dylan Sather. Hey. How
are you, Dylan? Good. Good. Thank you for
having me, David. No. No. It's my pleasure.
I know it's it's not hyperbole when I
say that this is my favorite SaaS product,
and I I'm really looking forward to showing
people it today. Awesome. Mhmm.
Do you wanna just give yourself a quick
introduction,
and then we'll kinda talk about Pipedream after
that?
Sure.
Yes. So I am one of eight cofounders
at Pipedream.
I'll go into a little bit of our
team history in a moment, but we've worked
together for about ten years as a team.
We founded Pipedream just a couple of years
ago and then launched Pipedream in October of
twenty nineteen officially.
I've done a little bit of engineering,
data science, teaching in my career, but I
really love right now, I I do a
lot of developer advocacy work for Pipedream,
and so happy to share with everyone. I'm
really excited to show it off.
Awesome.
Do you have a few slides, I believe,
that we're gonna run through? Yes.
I mean, we could talk about Pipedream first
if you want or we can do the
slides and then we have a little bit
of a chat. It's up to you. Yeah.
We'll give I'll I'll give the 10,000 foot
view first. The slides kinda cover,
really the high level of what Pipedream is,
how people use it. I think that will
set the stage for
for the rest of the
conversation.
So can you see the presentation and present
mode okay? I can. Looks great. Great. Great.
Okay.
So I briefly went over this.
You know, my my technical title at Pipedream
is a product hacker. That just it's a
title that I invented at my former company,
BrightRole,
kinda captures the
multifaceted
nature of my role as a as a
technical cofounder here at Pipedream.
Again, I do a lot of developer advocacy
and some data science work, a little product
management work for us.
Formerly, I I taught data analytics at Berkeley
and was a data scientist at BrightRoll and
Instacart
for a couple years.
Like I mentioned, our team, there are eight
of us right now. We worked together for
about the past ten years, primarily at a
company called BrightRoll.
It was a video advertising
exchange
that did a lot of programmatic
delivery of advertising on the Internet. So it's
a lot of really high scale
and big data challenges there. I this to
David a little while ago. We actually used
Equinix at BrightRoll. We had a a big
cage down in, data center here in California.
So thank you, David, and Equinix.
Pipedream,
like I mentioned, launched in October 2019. It's
a little over a year ago, and we've
been building the platform and improving it ever
since.
So, fundamentally,
Pipedream is an integration platform. If you've heard
of or ever used tools like Zapier,
if Integromat,
Pipedream falls broadly into that category. I'll talk
about how we're similar to those tools and
also how we're different. So
an integration platform fundamentally just helps you automate
workflows
often between
or within applications.
Apps is a broad term. You know, by
that, I mean, any API
or service provided by some app.
Pipedream workflows
are event driven, and this is pretty common
with these platforms.
So some event
typically triggers
a workflow that can be an HTTP request,
an email,
an event from a third party API or
SaaS service. And then when that event occurs,
we run some workflow, some set of steps
that define our automation.
So, for example,
it's a common ones. Every time a new
file is uploaded to Google Drive, I wanna
receive an email. So I might wanna watch
a specific folder and get notified immediately when
someone uploads a file.
I might save tweets to Google Sheets if
I'm, you a data scientist and do an
analysis on some political tweets, for example. I
may wanna just save all of those for
archival
and analysis later.
Pipedream, like many integration platforms, supports cron jobs.
So every day, I wanna run a SQL
query, send those results to Slack.
And, you know, Pipedream, many platforms,
do have this generic HTTP
interface. So I can spin up a workflow.
I get an HTTP endpoint.
I can send any HTTP request to that
endpoint,
and then, for example, you know, save the
payload to s three or some storage somewhere.
So where Pipedream differs than the other integration
platform most other integration platforms that I mentioned
before.
We squarely target developers.
So I wanna go through what this means.
Fundamentally,
at the top, this diagram, I think, kind
of explains the the general premise of Pipedream
well. Like I mentioned, you have triggers. Okay?
The trigger can be an HTTP request,
an incoming Slack message.
Whatever starts your workflow,
that event is the trigger.
Now in Pipedream,
I could run any Node. Js code that
I want. We have thousands of prepackaged steps
that we call actions. We'll go over some
of these today.
Actions are just
node code that someone else wrote and packaged
it such that Pipedream provides a UI
for interacting with that step. You don't have
to write the note code. You can just
use the preexisting code that we've written. But
behind the scenes, everything is actually note code,
and you can write your own.
So I have a lot of workflows where
I trigger an event on some incoming event
from AWS, for example.
And then I run custom node code without
using any of the pre built steps because
my workflow is is very custom to my
use case. Right? Nobody's created a step for
that before. So Pipedream gives you this flexibility.
And then we also have managed off. This
is one of the other secret sauces of
Pipedream that integration platforms do well.
We essentially let you one click a lot
into
hundreds of apps. Some apps, you enter your
API key because that's the way that integration
works. But Pipedream stores that authorization
information,
and then it uses that within your workflow.
So we, for example, refresh
authorization token so that you manage none
of what is often a complex off process
for these apps. You just one click, you're
in, and you can use your own account
and get access to your resources.
Some of Pipedream's key ideas, just to reiterate
some of these things,
I shouldn't have to write code to build
a workflow. So we we do this is
why we see ourselves as similar to the
Zapier's of the if this, then that's of
the world.
Even as an engineer, I don't want to
write code if I'm just developing a quick
integration. Right? If it's tangential to
my core workflow,
I just wanna get it out and get
something working. Okay? But the key idea is
that I can write code. Right? If I
need to extend it, I wanna be able
to get into the code and modify it
slightly if that step doesn't quite suit my
needs.
When I do write code, it should be
easy.
I shouldn't have to spin up,
for example, a a Docker container or a
pod in Kubernetes just to run a basic
workflow. Right? I shouldn't have to create a
AWS Lambda script.
In the end, right, I just wanna be
able to quickly write code, deploy it, test
it, and ship it. So we'll go into
how that development workflow works in Pipedream.
I mentioned that everything is JavaScript. Okay? So
even the prebuilt steps that you use in
Pipedream, it's all just node code. You can
click into a step and modify it in
any way you want. When you write custom
node code, you can require any NPM package.
So you can extend,
Pipedream to, you know, the NPM ecosystem.
Integrations are open source. Okay. So all the
actions that we provide,
again, you can see and modify that code
to suit your needs. We'll talk about event
sources. Event sources fundamentally are workflow triggers, I
mentioned.
Anytime you receive a new tweet,
run your workflow.
That
trigger, right, anytime I receive a new tweet,
we call that an event source.
Those are also open source in our GitHub
repo, and I'll show you a link to
that at the end.
So anyone can submit PRs for new triggers,
anyone can modify
any existing event sources.
We have things that, again, as a developer
platform,
we have expectations of developers for, I need
to maintain state across executions.
I need a key value store, for example.
I need to manage the concurrency and rate
limiting.
I might need to serialize the execution of
my workflows.
If I'm managing state that depends on a
single execution finishing before the next begins, or
I have a downstream API
that's rate limited. So I have to make
sure incoming events are buffered
and then are executed at a given rate
limit so I don't hit those rate limits
in my downstream service.
So all of the controls that you expect
from,
you know, again, a mature
platform,
that provides state and these controls Pipedream provides.
We
also believe that, low volume workflow should be
free,
and, currently,
our free tier provides a hundred thousand invocations.
So I can run a workflow that's an
invocation.
Hundred thousand invocations per month. Okay?
There are daily caps and some other platform
limits that we embed, but fundamentally,
we love to provide the platform for free
so people can use it. If you need
to run more than a hundred thousand invocations
a month, you can upgrade to our professional
tier.
So the last slide, I just wanted to
this will segue nicely into what David and
I are gonna do today.
But, you know, we often hear the question
for new Pipedream developers. Where does Pipedream fit
into my stack?
So I wanted to call out four common
use cases just to kind of pin those
in your mind.
One, one of the most common ones is
I have an asynchronous
HTTP
driven workflow.
The trigger here is just an example of
the HTTP driven workflow.
But, fundamentally, I have some logic where I
wanna send, for example, an HTTP request to
Pipedream,
and then Pipedream manage all the other logic
for what I'm gonna do in my workflow.
But Pipedream responds immediately
to me with a 200 okay. Once I
send the request, Pipedream says, I've got it,
and I'm gonna run the rest of this
logic asynchronously.
And Pipedream workflows can run up to five
minutes for each indication.
So, again, Pipedream is handling all of that
workflow logic async, and you can continue to
send events, get that immediate 200 okay response
to process that. I linked to a workflow
here that actually handles our
new user sign up flow. This is a
common one. So we just send the HTTP
request with the user's email, their name.
We send the user an email behind the
scenes. We track it for analytics purposes, etcetera.
We also provide the ability to create your
own HTTP APIs.
So if you need to respond back to
the client,
you can do that from a Pipedream workflow.
Right? So incoming request comes.
I hit some third party API from the
workflow.
I crunch the data, and I respond with
that back to the client. One of the
simplest examples is I can actually turn a
Google spreadsheet
into a JSON API.
So take the data I have in a
spreadsheet, return it back, format it as JSON
to the client.
Cron jobs are a big one for us.
I believe Pipedream is one of the easiest
ways to run a Cron job. Hopefully, we
can just show that off really quickly today.
Internally,
you know, we run a lot of SQL
queries through database checks.
Send a lot of custom metrics to CloudWatch,
for example, on a schedule,
etcetera.
Finally, the big class of workflows is ones
that are triggered from, again, these SaaS or
third party API events.
Every time I get a new tweet, I
wanna send it to Google Sheets.
Internally, we do a lot with AWS.
So I have AWS events triggering a workflow,
and I'm making other AWS API calls.
Or, we do a lot with, again, our
professional plan. We have a lot of customers
via Stripe,
so we're handling a lot of internal workflows
there.
I linked to a workflow here that shows
how to send, anytime that customer cancels, how
to send that to Slack. We do some
other workflows related to that. So, again, these
four categories, it's not exclusive, but these are
a lot of the things people use Pipedream
workflows for.
That's it for now. I hope that gives
a good introduction to Pipedream.
And, yeah, we can hopefully kick it off
with some specific examples from here.
Yes. Thank you for that. I'm I'm I
think that sets the scene well. Hopefully, everyone
understands
the kind of the the value proposition.
And then now we get to get hands
on and actually show them how to put
some of this into practice, which is gonna
be really cool. So let me pop up
my screen.
So if anyone wants to follow along, the
docs are available at docs.pipedream.com.
A lot of what Dylan has just said
is also here along with a lot more
information. The docs are pretty nifty.
But I am feeling particularly brave today, so
we're just gonna go straight to my account.
So shall we try and break down some
of that vocabulary then that you've had in
your slides and that we have in front
of us here just to familiarize people with
what they're looking at from the the kind
of the dashboard point of view. So Yes.
So we have workflows. Do you wanna kinda
just tell us what a workflow is in
the context of Pipedream?
Yeah. A workflow
is specifically
a linear sequence
of steps.
The first step of a workflow maybe if
you want, we could just create a new
workflow now to walk people through it. So
you've got that blue new button.
What triggers should we use?
Well, we just start with the simple cron
scheduler? That's great. So, yeah, you can see
here. I'll I'll briefly
actually, maybe click the x because I I
skipped over probably a pretty important step. You
can delete any step at any time. So
when I create a new workflow,
I'm presented with this menu
of possible triggers that I can select.
The top option is I mentioned the term
event source. We'll talk about that in a
sec. But an event source is
a, you know, trigger essentially for a workflow
that wraps logic
for how to source that event from the
third party app or API.
So an event source for Twitter, for example,
again, lets me run a workflow on your
tweets. You also have these simple, what we
call native triggers,
HTTP,
Cron, email, and SDK.
Those four,
you have available to you at any time.
So I can create an HTTP endpoint.
And like David just did, we can create
a cron job. So we can select the
cron scheduler trigger,
and then our workflow will run on the
schedule we specify.
And, we have, you know, simple human readable.
I can schedule a workflow every hour, every
minute. You can enter a cron expression
in a time zone as well if you
want that level of control.
You have a a lot of options there.
So
we have a cron trigger.
You know, we can select any trigger at
this point and go ahead and deploy the
workflow to memorialize this. Once we deploy the
workflow, we have the trigger.
You also see this big run now button,
and that lets us trigger a workflow manually.
So we can do that for our tests.
You'll notice here, there's not a lot of
interesting information that comes in the event, but
the second that David clicked run now, notice
on the left,
we have this event and what we call
the inspector.
Okay? So that's just where incoming events live.
When we set a test event, we automatically
selected that event as well, that's why you
see this data in the top trigger step.
So the most interesting information, which we expand
by default, is the incoming event data.
And steps dot trigger dot event is the
name of the variable that allows you to
access that event data in future steps of
your workflow.
So for Cron,
again, it's not that interesting. And, typically, we
wouldn't access the actual event data, but you
do actually have the epic time stamp of
the indication.
And then the timer config there indicates this
is actually triggered manually
versus
triggered on its own schedule. So if you
wanted logic that maybe only ran on test
events, you could actually do that here, for
example.
If you briefly select steps dot trigger dot
context
and expand that accordion,
this is also metadata about the workflow invocation.
So for example, this also shows the time
stamp at which it ran. There's a unique
event ID that Pipedream assigned so that if
you wanted to store that in your own
downstream system,
you know, all the metadata here, your your
user ID,
the deployment ID is technically
it it changes every new version you deploy
of your workflow.
Briefly,
I'll just also mention at the top header,
just above the workflow, you'll notice a couple
of things.
You can add a title to your workflow,
you know, my awesome cron job or whatever.
You'll notice we we made a couple of
edits, and so we're already on version three.
But if you click on that drop down,
you can always revert back to a previous
version of your workflow as well.
And, you'll see the code in read only
mode. You can then redeploy that version if
you want or go back to the latest
version.
Code is always private by default, but you
can make it public. And so a lot
of the workflows in the slide deck that
I I shared that we'll share later, we've
made those workflows public so that you can
see it, and then you can copy that
for your own use case. So that's one
interesting thing about the open source nature of
Pipedream we love is, you know, I've written
a workflow once. I can share that with
someone. You can copy it. You can remix
it in any way you want. Right? So
public workflows
are really nice for, sharing code in that
manner.
Your data is always private. We're actually working
on a feature to allow even data to
be made public,
which is also an interesting use case for
demo purposes. Right? Or I wanna show off
an event stream.
I wanna create an analysis. Again, I'm a
data scientist, and I'm processing tweets. I wanna
actually show those incoming tweets and show how
that data
changes to the course of the workflow,
right, to show step by step
all the transformations I'm doing. So that'll come
later, but, again, by default, code's private, data's
private.
And then we've we've got our
trigger step now.
And like I mentioned, you know, workflows are,
right now, a linear sequence of steps.
So we show the option then to create
the next step, and this is where actions
come in.
So you'll and if you scroll down a
little bit, you'll see below this a list
of common apps as well, but you can
search for anything
in the search bar at the very top
of the step selector.
So what kind of code do you wanna
run? Do you wanna just run Node JS
code or run a custom action for this?
Yeah. Why don't we just run some Node
JS code now, and then we'll maybe add
on a couple more to run through some
of the more common ones and take it
from there. Cool.
So the very first option, run Node JS
code.
Notice that at the very top of the
step, by default, this step has a name.
It's step stop Node JS.
And that'll become important later because
when steps
return data,
we are able to reference that data at
that step's namespace.
And so I'll walk through that in a
second, but just remember that all steps are
named.
I can connect apps to this custom step.
So if I wanted to write custom note
code where I interacted with the Spotify API,
for example, I could connect my Spotify account.
And, you can do that by clicking the
plus button at the very top left of
it. We won't do this now, but, if
you click on that, it should open a
modal
that allows you to select any
app and then an associated account
you would select for that app. So, again,
even custom Node JS code, you can actually
connect apps so that you have access to
your authorization data.
For now, maybe just, you know, do a
console log statement, and we can see how
that works.
Easy.
Awesome.
Awesome. So we also have keyboard shortcuts,
and, depends on your platform, but, command d
on a Mac and control d on a
PC or Linux should deploy your workflow,
you can click on the deploy button up
there.
But now, you know, notice the version at
the top, increment, it's version four. Right? So
every every deploy you make cuts a new
version of your workflow,
deploys it to a whole new execution
environment on the back end. I should note
that everyone's workflows are sandboxed
inside
every version of a workflow, technically, is sandboxed
inside its own virtual machine.
So all the memory and disk is yours
and yours alone.
Go ahead and click run now again,
and let's take a look at what this
produces.
So
any console logs, any standard output or standard
error shows up below the step that produced
it. Okay? So any logs
you wanna log, you just put a console
log statement there, and you're good. Now notice
we say no return values or exports
for this step.
You have you worked with custom step exports?
I believe so. Yes. You mean when you
use desktop to set something? Exactly.
Exactly. So we have this concept that we
call step exports.
Return values work the same way, and we
can maybe show off both. But
if you deselect
the event
just by clicking on the event in the
inspector and get back to the code,
just below the console log step, maybe we
can add a step export to show people
how this works.
So
notice David's type this dot name. Okay?
When I deploy and run this, let's maybe
just see end to end how it works
because it's easy to show up with the
observability.
So we've got that original console log statement,
and now we see steps .nodejs
dot name data.
So, again, the name of my step is
steps.nodejs.
Steps Node j s Name,
I exported from
steps
dot Node. Js by saying this dot name.
So the context of steps
you know, JavaScript
if you're familiar with JavaScript, you probably hate
this.
It took me a long time to learn
this, especially as an old data scientist, one
from Python. But
in the context of steps, this just refers
to the current step.
By saying this dot name equals value, I
export that value
at that step dot property name. So in
this case, name. If you hover over that
row, you'll see the option to copy either
the variable path steps dot no g s
dot name or the value.
Okay? So in future steps, I can reference
that export
against,
workflows as linear sequence of steps.
And so,
when I run one step, I get access
to that data. Maybe just a console log
it, and we can confirm that everything
works okay.
There we go.
So
a lot of our actions,
for again, common apps like Twitter and Spotify,
etcetera, you know, that's all pre baked to
note code. They have their own step exports.
They return data automatically,
and then you'll often see that data below
a step.
I
think there's
I mean, we covered quite a lot there,
but I just wanna highlight some of the
things that I think just make this such
a cool platform to be building on top
of.
So
firstly, the event inspector on the left is
invaluable when you start to connect to other
sources and triggers where you don't really understand
what the payload is gonna be like yet.
And the auto complete and the ability to
copy the pass from these
tools
inside of each step are also invaluable. Like,
see those two things alone are just phenomenal.
And I think as we start to build
out more, why that is so cool will
definitely become apparent to people. The automatic versioning
is very, very cool. I love the idea
of making my things public. What actually happens
for me personally is that my code is
so awful. I think I'll clean that up
later
and then make it public. But at the
same time, it works and then I never
clean it up. So, like, you know, double
edged sword for me at least anyway.
But being able to share them is very,
very cool.
And, yeah, the authentication thing, again, you know,
not having to manage off for any of
this, you know, the ability to just click,
hey.
I wanna do something with Spotify and have
that automatically pass in my credentials to that
step for me to consume.
We're very very, very cool. Cool. Good to
hear.
Alright. Let's do something a little bit more
tangible then. That's like a good plan. So
let's just I guess we don't need to
create a new workflow. I'll just clean this
up a little bit.
We're not gonna go with cron. Should we
bring in the Twitter integration?
Yeah. Let's do it.
Alright. So let's filter on Twitter.
And
So
this is this is part of our UX
that
we are currently optimizing,
actually. But to create a did you wanna
create a new Twitter source?
Yeah. I did. So then I tried to
filter, but I think I need to scroll
down. But So
that you know, you should be able to
search Twitter, see Twitter, and create it. Right
now, you have to click create event source,
and then that brings you into the menu
for creating any so event source is just
to reiterate, right, are, essentially just workflow triggers.
You can do a lot more with event
sources, so we can talk about that later
if we have the time. But you create
an event source to create a,
trigger from a third party SaaS app. Select
the app.
You've got a range of specific sources.
Let's do search mentions.
And this this connect button is always my
favorite thing because that's the old one. And
I just go, hey. Cool.
Yeah.
Yeah. If you didn't have an existing account,
you would be prompted to
authorize Pipedream's access to your Twitter account with
our Pipedream app,
and you'd be good to go.
So I'll just add
this hashtag. I have I've never actually used
this hashtag on a show. I'm just gonna
this is the first time. So, you know,
I think there's only two sample tweets that
I was doing with earlier. But we'll do
a search for Rawkode live,
recent.
We can filter it to not include retweets
or not include replies.
The language filter,
locale.
Like, there there's loads of ways to be
able to interact. Like, I don't need to
understand the Twitter API.
Like, someone else has already went to the
effort and contributed this the project,
which is great.
And
but, Claudia, you're doing this It took
a it us a while. Event sources
can be pretty difficult to build, and it
really depends on the third party API. But,
again, you can take a look at all
the source code in GitHub for this if
you did wanna understand how it works and
you didn't wanna tweak it.
We
I I think you may have seen,
but if you scroll down just a little
bit before you create source, you also can
see the component code,
right there.
We
again, the the diction, I think, is one
of the hardest parts when you're getting familiar
with Pipedream because we do use a lot
of specific terms.
Components
are, just this term for a a Node.
Js module
that, is written in a specific format to
create things like event sources.
So, that's all that is is, the component
is just the event source. It's a node
module. You can see how it works. When
you create the source, you can even edit
that source
on your own. So in your account, that
event source gets created. But if you click
edit code and configuration,
then you can edit. You can change the
configuration if you wanted to and you can
edit the code. So all of that's available
to you.
Nice.
And we actually see I think this is
one of the I have a lot of
favorite things about Pipedream. So that's this here.
This preview of what the event data worked
with. Because, obviously, I'm gonna wanna do something
with this and just being able to see
that and be able to copy the past
and stuff is really Mhmm. Mhmm.
I hear you. There's my last tweet.
Nice. Nice. Yeah.
Alright. So Sorry,
Nico.
No. Okay. So let's try and do something
with this.
Now there's a loads there's loads of integrations
that we can play with. We spoke briefly
just before we went live, and I said,
hey, it would be cool if we could
have people tweet Rawkode live as a hashtag
and the name of a song, and we're
gonna try and attempt to look up that
song on Spotify and add it to a
playlist.
So let's see if we can get that
going. So that that's that's your queue. People
are watching. If you can use the Rawkode
live hashtag
and just type the name of a song
and then we'll do our best to try
and add that to a playlist.
And if you all don't do it, I'll
just tweet my own. That's okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Just means I'll prefer the music anyway.
So I'm gonna click send us test event.
And now we can begin to work with
this data. So
I guess the first thing we need to
do is
look up the tweet text or maybe split
the tweet text. See, I never really thought
this through today. It's probably harder than I
thought it was gonna be. Let's just let's
just assume the only bit of text that
comes through is just the name of a
song.
Cool. So we'll just go straight to the
lookup stage. We're not gonna try and parse
anything.
Cool.
And let's see.
Do we need I'm assuming because
is there a get track?
Let's see.
Yeah. Let's see.
We'll just So we'll just check.
Right. It's oh, yeah. I guess so I
think get tracks
might take the Spotify ID
for that track.
But I think there's a search action
that
I'm not sure exactly how the Spotify API
works, but we can work through it.
Try
try just doing Spotify,
and then you'll see a search for an
item, get slash Oh, there we go. Yeah.
Let's connect this up,
and then we could just pass in the
terms. So let's assume
we're using the previous event that we have
here
that the full text is what we want.
So
In fact, we will need to remove the
Rawkode live from it.
There. The plot seconds. Okay. So we're gonna
add a custom
step before we do that then
where we wanna take
our full text.
We can just paste this in.
And this is a string. I already know
that's a string, and I'm getting all complete.
So let's just do a really crude
replace.
And then I this is where your knowledge
is gonna come in. Does this update in
line and I'll have access to that, or
should I try and set
something like this? Yeah. You will
either do this dot song title or you
can just return
steps dot trigger.
Both of those would give you access to
return value.
And then that's
you know, let's let's see if I'm correct.
I think that dollar return value reference
should be accessible in
the param selector of the next step.
The value you won't see a a a
value associated with it. But if you select
steps,
Node. Js, return dollar return value. Right? That's
when you use return
instead of a specific sec step export, that's
how we represent that.
Okay.
And then this one's a type, so I'm
gonna say track.
And then I think you had an ST
at the front of the search the query
brand.
Good catch. And,
yeah, I think let's give it a try.
Alright.
No one's tweeted me yet. I'm disappointed, so
I'm going to say
My team should be listening too, and there's
some music fans there. So, hopefully,
someone
someone has a good song in mind.
Alright. Well, I have now tweeted a song.
I'm gonna head deploy. Let's just let this
run.
And
this is now on
what was it? Fifteen seconds we set this
up for?
Yeah. I think so.
Nice. I guess for now, we can have
the test event, which will be my last
previous tweet. And we should still be able
to see at least the response come back
with, I would assume, nothing.
Yeah. Let's see what Spotify does with that.
Okay. So
let's see.
Yeah. There's a return value and a dead
remove or hashtag.
It's good.
Magically, we got some songs. No. We didn't.
We got seven fields, but no items. Right.
Right. Right.
Alright.
I didn't enable the trigger. There we go.
And then if you scroll up,
you'll go ahead and deselect the
specific event again.
And then,
under the test banner, go ahead and expand
that test accordion
and hit that refresh
button.
And
now go so this is, you know, one
of your test suites still that I that
there we go. Your new one should show
up there. There's a again, we're working on
this UX to improve it. It's a couple
of steps just to get that new test
data in there.
Okay. So let's just send this as a
test event and make sure our workflow does
hopefully
what we wanted it to.
Let's see.
So it removed the hashtag,
and we got 20 options.
This is good.
And so it looks like someone else might
have tweeted as well because you see that
another event came in just above it.
Well, that that may be the actual trigger
pulling in my event.
No. It's not. It's someone else. Yeah. When
you so when you selected that, you know,
turn on the trigger
switch,
that turned the trigger live such that now
we are receiving live events. But it looks
like it's working, so maybe that's fine.
Nice.
Well, that's a good start. Let me pull
them up.
Yeah. Okay. Cool. We just have someone else
tweet. Thank you, Frank.
Yeah. Thanks.
If you this
is,
the the reason we have that toggle so
that while you're developing your
pause the live stream of them and then
turn it live once you develop your workflow.
Okay. So we're
not gonna do anything sophisticated here. We'll just
grab the first response from this items list,
and let's add that to a playlist.
Let me get my Spotify up as well.
Let's see.
But what we have here is an empty
Pipedream
playlist. Let's see if we can get this
going.
So we just wanna add another step. We're
using the selector.
I'm pretty sure there isn't oh,
we ought to scroll down. There is an
add track. I'm sure I looked for this.
Let's
see.
Add tracks to playlist.
Alright.
Let's
see. How do I get my
Spotify ID?
Are
you still there? Oh, I think I lost
Dylan.
Alright. I'll just keep mumbling through it. Let's
see. How did I get the ID?
Yeah. Can you hear me okay now?
Yep. You're you seem to be back now.
I'm not sure what happened there. Can you
hear me okay now?
Yeah. I can hear you.
Yep.
Yeah. Thank you, Frank. Appreciate it.
Okay. So
I wonder if there's a way for me
to get my Spotify
ID from
here.
Let's connect it.
Dylan's definitely gone there.
Alright. I'm just gonna log in to the
Spotify web interface to get those IDs.
Oh, and he's back.
There you go.
Welcome back. I yeah. I moved to a
place with that with better WiFi. I hope
you can hear me okay.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. You're you're sounding good now.
Great. So I was just gonna log in
to the Spotify web interface cause I realized
I didn't know how to get my Spotify
user ID.
There there is a
get me
endpoint in Spotify.
I think we should have an action for
that, and that should return your user ID.
So you may wanna add that,
you know, near the top of your workflow.
Good idea. Alright. It's about it.
Yep. Got me. There we go.
Connect.
And I'm just gonna assume I'm gonna wanna
list playlist as well.
So let's see.
Users playlists.
Cool. Alright. So
what we want to do is
save. I'm gonna have to remove the playlist
or not, like, because I can't satisfy that.
I can make it up. Right. A b
c one. Yeah. And if
you'd like, do you see when you hover
over the step, there's that green toggle in
the top right?
Yeah. There we go. And if you want,
you could just disable any of these steps.
Right?
Alright. Let's just turn these off just now.
So we should be in a position where
if I deploy this, I'm now gonna be
requesting my own profile information from Spotify.
Have to use their ID, pass it into
the get playlist one, get the playlist ID,
and then add our track to the playlist.
I like the way this is coming together.
Well, yeah. It's it's it's nice to see
how I mean, that these are things that
people are gonna have to do as they
start to play with it and explore with
it. And it's nice you you don't need
to leave less workflow experience to do any
of that either. So Mhmm. Right.
Alright. So get me.
Let's oh, we need to click run.
If you expand the test accordion one more
time,
it should
go ahead and deselect this event
and then expand the test accordion
at the Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
We go. And then send it.
See, I know this stuff. I'm just
being silly.
Alright.
Okay. There's me. There's my ID.
So I'm gonna enable the playlist action.
We're gonna drop in our user ID here.
I'm gonna deploy this.
And then we're gonna come back up here
and run this again.
And now we should get a list of
playlists.
There we go.
So I have eight. I'll assume the recent
one is this one. Nope. That's my refs
playlist.
Film scores for coding,
covers.
You know, you're getting an insight into my
music.
Boost.
Of course, it was the first one, wasn't
it? And
this is the ID that we want. So
I'm gonna disable
this.
I'm gonna enable our
ad,
and we pop open these params.
We can put in the playlist ID, and
then we drop the user ID again,
which is here.
And then we need to just ensure
that we pass through a track URI from
the search as well.
So let's disable to get me.
And today, move
the track there. It's just above
this last yeah.
K.
I'm gonna need to run a test event.
So let's just deploy this
and do this.
Alright. So let's do an emojis step,
skipping over those, and here's a search.
And it's got an href, which I'm assuming
is all we need.
You know, that href looks like
the reference for
that query.
You're correct. Yeah. Inside.
And it's funny that it returned multiple items,
but I guess we could just take the
first one. Right? Yeah. We'll just grab the
first one. So we've got this items with
20 songs that it found. We want this
URI, so we're gonna use the helper copy
path.
We're gonna re enable this.
Pop open the params.
Add our variable,
and deploy.
And that may
just be crazy enough to work.
Alright. I'll just fire for the same test
event.
And then now we'll see if the Spotify
app oh, wow. There we go. Awesome.
Awesome. That was fun.
That was. I love the
just the iteration of, like, having to get
my user ID. And it's it's all the
grunt work involved in every integration, like you
said. Right? It it it's tough to piece
the steps together, and the problem is just
always more complex when you work with these
third party APIs.
But, yeah, we think the observability and the
testing at least helps as much as we
can.
Definitely.
Alright. Now just because, Frank, you were kind
enough to send me this, I'm gonna send
your event through too.
Just to see what we get in the
playlist, and then we'll move on to another
demo.
Come on. There we go. And flames. Good
chin.
Awesome. Thank you, Frank. That was fun. Awesome.
Alright.
What else are you feeling? Anything
you wanna pick up here?
Let's see. Let's you wanna do some stuff
with Discord.
Right? Yeah. Let's do something with Discord. Yeah.
So
we have I can't remember if there's a
Discord.
Do we want no.
Yeah.
I'm just having an internal monologue for myself
so you're not invited to. So Yeah. Yeah.
Let's create an event source. We have Discord
already connected.
I think we did Discord
bot, and then we did a
You had the Pipedream bot installed on your
guild. Right? I do. Yes. Go ahead and
try to select Discord,
actually.
And
as long as you select the the same
off provision, the same, you know, guild that
you had, then I think this should work.
And the the reason so we have two
Discord integrations. There's the Discord one where we
install the Pipedream bot in your guild. That
actually allows us to listen for new messages
immediately.
So you add a new message to whatever
channel you wanna listen to.
You can actually select multiple channels here. Right?
And then Pipedream
should ping this event source,
immediately.
If you use the Discord bot integration,
you can run your own bot. So if
that's your use case, you could actually set
up your own bot in your guild, connect
that bot to Pipedream.
That integration, though, runs on a cron since
there's no real time integration for listening for
bot messages. So can kinda see these event
sources. Some work instantly
because there's a webhook or a WebSocket integration
that talks to Pipedream.
Some, because the API doesn't support webhooks, we
have to run on a schedule like you
did for Twitter. So just a a brief
description kind of of, you know, that's all
the work that we do. We build an
event source internally.
Nice. Okay.
So
let's just see your discord method. Let's get
this live.
Great. So
why don't we
just have it relay messages onto my Twitter
account then? What can go wrong with that?
So
it's right now it's it's listening for an
event. So
did I prepare?
I did. Okay. So we can just see.
Hello.
Livestream.
You're saying that should be yeah. That was
pretty instant there. Awesome. Okay.
So
let's do something with that. Now I do
have my Twitter connected too.
We can just have this post a tweet.
Do you wanna do anything in in the
middle first or just post it direct? Yeah.
Let's let's try direct to make sure it
works. Then maybe we could could decorate it,
you know, somewhat of a Spotify example. I'm
just let me think about, like, data we
could get about it. Right? Like, I feel
like there's another API we could use
in the middle. Yeah. I wonder if we
could do some sort of
guest lookup or something like that to attach
to it. We're doing it great with Giphy,
and so that that's a great example.
Alright. So in fact, I'll just copy the
path here instead of
picking something random. So let's see what do
we have.
Let's then click the author name.
Rawkode
says,
where was my message?
Hello, livestream.
I guess, content. Is that just escaped, I
guess? Yeah. I I actually don't know. That's
funny. Well,
we're we'll find out. So
we're now set our status.
We can just deploy this.
I guess what we've done is just to
save you that we're gonna replicate all the
messages from here.
This is really to my from
my Discord
with.
Oh, I didn't turn on.
I
know. We're it's one of the UX things
we we need to improve. But the the
the event should have come in. So if
you select it as a test event, should
work. But, yeah, you could try that again.
Perfect. And
let's go check out my Twitter.
Rawkode says this is really it from my
Discord with Pipedream. Okay. Let's do something a
bit more fun with this then. Not that
that wasn't fun, but we can tell. So
you said to us, I've never played with
the Gaffee integration.
So
let's see.
What we need to do? Search.
Gif search, I guess. Gif search, I believe,
is the one. Yeah.
API key.
Yes. Yes.
Alright. I'll do that
over here.
Think I have a Giphy account.
And
An interesting bit, but I'm promised. Second.
Telling me it sent me a two factor
code, but I don't have one.
Alright. Okay. Let's scratch that plan.
Yeah. I'm looking through some other,
you know, text
decoration APIs,
like anything that we could pass
text to. I guess, you know, one thing
you
could do
I forget if Giphy has any public
API endpoints. I don't know if they do.
There is a are you a Star Wars
fan?
Yeah.
Star
Wars API.
And,
you know, I'm wondering if we could just,
just as an example, you know, hit that
API to decorate it with
some
you know, you can, for instance, get a
a random starship or a species or a
planet. They have APIs actually for listing
all those resources.
So we could we could just decorate it
with that as a simple example.
There's
yeah. What do what do you think about
that? There's there's a Reddit integration that we
could use.
Yeah. Well, what's the Star Wars API? We'll
just we'll we'll just we don't even need
to use it. We're just we're just composing
random stuff here. So Yeah. Yeah. So if
you search for a a new step, it's
technically
Swapi, SWAPI.
K.
It starts it.
Yeah. And I think maybe just try the
return random character name. Like, that that wraps
a little bit of logic.
You'll notice they have a a people API.
And so, you know, if you hit that,
you get a list of people back. We
just happen to return a random
Star Wars character. Right?
And and then you can use that return
value in future steps. Let's make sure that
still works.
Yeah. So I just disabled the auto tweet.
And then what we'll do is we'll fire
through one test event, and then we'll see
what we get back from
Rawkode.
We got CTPOs.
I'm gonna copy the path, re enable our
tweet.
And instead of me tweeting it then, we'll
just say
that the author is a random stuff.
Not?
So that's all enabled.
Oh, yeah. I'll send the discourse manager. So
let's see.
So somebody from Star Wars
says,
hello.
These are the correct droids.
I know.
There we go.
We got that. We got that. And we
posted the tweet. So our two t two
says these are
Awesome.
We rushed Twitter account.
And there we go. Awesome. I like that.
That was good. Do you wanna go into
some of the there there are some advanced
settings here that I think could be interesting
to peruse
just to kinda take this and,
you know, we've obviously been playing around with
some kind of trivial
if this then, you know, do this. But
I wanted to show off some more advanced
examples where,
for example, like, concurrency,
can come into play.
Yeah. Let's do it. Okay.
So if you go into your settings,
near the top
Right. So I just wanna walk through we
can walk through each of these because they're
they're actually all interesting features of Pipedream.
First of all,
we we haven't talked about errors because you
actually haven't made any. So congratulations.
Cool that we've gotten this far without throwing
any error.
Maybe we can do that just to see
how it works in a moment. But at
a high level,
Pipedream
will, number one, display
any error that's thrown by a node step
within the step and show you very clearly,
you know, what step that happened in, and
we try to surface as much information as
we can about the error. We also
forward that error to what we call the
global error workflow.
By default,
maybe if you open this in a new
tab, we can just take a look. Have
you messed around with this at all?
So I only noticed the global error workflow
maybe a couple of days ago. I wasn't
sure if I just missed it all this
time or if it was near. So Yeah.
It you know, it's meant to be hidden
because it it runs on autopilot.
Now the the idea is, by default, this
is just another workflow.
So if an error happens in one of
your workflows,
it just sends the error to this workflow.
And this workflow
sends you an email with all the details
of the errors. You've probably gotten those emails
before, I imagine, when you when you have
an error.
But in essence, you know, by default, you'll
receive one email
per unique error per workflow
every twenty four hours.
So all that means is we don't wanna
spam you. If you have a high volume
workflow that throws the same exact error, you'll
only get one email in a twenty four
hour period.
But if you get a new error, you'll
get a new email. Right? Because it's a
new issue. You need to troubleshoot.
So by default, this workflow handles all that
logic for you. If you you know, this
logic is just what I described. But if
you scroll down briefly,
you'll see the
email,
me step.
So you can email yourself
from any Pipedream workflow.
There's this action, email me, that you can
search for in any workflow. You can also
use this special
function in node,
dollar send dot email.
So dollar send
exposes
bunch of these special functions, dollar send dot
email, dollar send dot s three,
dollar send dot h t t p
is a Pipedream built integration for quickly sending
data to common destinations like that. Email is
just one of those destinations.
So, again, we're essentially just dogfooding
our own product tier by creating this workflow
and then letting it drive your error notifications
for all of your workflows.
And the cool thing is since it's a
workflow, you can modify it in any way
you want.
If you wanted to send oh, and you
did. There we go. That's awesome.
Yeah. But I noticed the new well, I
thought it was a new feature. I was
like, hell, I wonder if I can send
all the errors to my Discord. Although I
haven't had any errors yet. So Right.
Yeah. Exactly. This is exactly what we hope
people will do. Right? If you use Discord
or Slack or what you know, Telegram, right,
you should be able to send
messages to your destination of choice. So the
global error workflow, if you go back to
your workflow settings,
you know, that's essentially by default, it's on.
There's a ton of other you know, I
wish we had time to cover this. I
I don't think it's worth going into the
whole API today.
But I'll briefly show you if you look
at our API docs back in back in
docs.
Mhmm. And then
scroll down to the
API
section.
Go to the REST API.
This
lists all of our API endpoints we expose
in our REST API.
There's a lot that you can do. The
reason I thought of this is
we have an endpoint for retrieving the workflow
errors via API.
So if, for example, you wanted highly custom
error handling,
you know, for a specific workflow,
'd actually get the workflow errors for a
specific workflow,
send those to a custom workflow.
It's similar to
are you familiar with AWS Lambda? Do you
work with Lambda at all?
I have done in the past. Yeah. Yeah.
There's, you know, there's concepts in Lambda and
in other systems where you essentially have an
error handler per Lambda function.
Right?
The global error workflow, I think, simplifies it
because you don't need to think about error
handling. Right? All errors by default are sent
to this global workflow. You get an email,
you deal with them. But the idea is
if you want that advanced control
for, I wanna handle errors for this workflow
in this specific way,
you can actually have your own
error handling workflow set up for a specific
workflow.
And some of the endpoints here with workflows
and specifically subscriptions
allow you to subscribe
to errors or events
from specific workflows.
So, you know, the UI is really just
a skin on top of all of this.
But behind the scenes,
you have a lot of capabilities to really
extend how workflows work. So, again, if you
wanna listen for workflow errors,
you can do that. If you want multiple
triggers for one workflow,
you can actually set that up as well.
And it it works in all different directions.
So these the subscription model via API allows
you to essentially have a workflow subscribed to
events coming in from multiple sources.
You can then have those workflows in mid
events and have other work multiple workflows subscribe
to those.
So for pretty complex workflows,
some people need these capabilities.
And, you know, I just wanted to highlight
that it's possible
via the rest API. So if you're interested,
take a look at the docs.
That's well, one of the meant the one
of the use cases you mentioned there is
something I actually tried to do this week
was have multiple triggers on our workflow.
So
Yeah. Nice to know that I can do
that advice and Yeah. Yeah. We we were
still working on all the UI components.
So you'll you'll be able to list and
create
the triggers
via the API. You won't see it in
the UI yet,
but, you know, we're we're working on all
of that.
The the next things I wanted to show
off, you know, you, by default,
have this time out of thirty seconds. If
your workflow runs for longer than thirty seconds,
it would time out, but you can increase
that up to three hundred seconds, up to
five minutes.
We keep it at thirty seconds because, you
know, we don't want you to make a
mistake
and then have your workflow just run, run,
run and use your compute time because on
the free tier, you are capped on on
compute time on a daily quota.
It's pretty generous again. So most people don't
hit it. But, again, we default to thirty
seconds just to keep you under that cap.
But for long running workflows, it does make
sense to increase it.
And then under that, you'll see you have
a lot of controls over throttling and concurrency.
So I mentioned both of these earlier.
But,
concurrency, I think, is the easiest one to
understand for people. Right? Like, you can,
if you check the limit concurrency,
box,
by default,
this serializes the execution of your workflow. So
if there's something you're doing in your workflow
where you're handling state
and that state should not be mutated by
multiple executions of the same workflow,
right, where you have some global shared, like,
singleton state,
you can serialize your workflow here so that
incoming Discord messages. Right? If you get multiple
messages at the same time, we'll queue up
those messages and then only run your workflow
one message at a time. Right?
The throttling works in combination if you want.
Right? You could
but normally,
you know, you might you might use it,
like I mentioned earlier, with a rate limit
use case. Like, let's say you receive the
Discord messages,
you're doing something with the Spotify API.
Spotify API might have its own rate limit,
and so you need to balance
the incoming messages with that Spotify rate limit
so that you don't hit you know, if
you get a thousand matches at once from
Discord,
you may get rate limited on Spotify sense.
You can throttle the execution to only run,
say,
60 events every minute, right, if that's the
Spotify rate limit.
So this is where the advanced controls really
come in to play. Like, it's again, it's
subtle. Right? But with with APIs, especially, we
see it all the time. You have either
state related issues.
Like, if you're even writing to Google Sheets,
it's not a state related issue. But if
you blast
this
Discord source with messages and try to send
all those messages to Google Sheets,
parallel executions of the workflow will overwrite the
same row.
And so you wanna manage that, right, you
have to serialize it.
All these controls come into play for complex
workflow, so that's why we built them.
Nice.
Alright.
So let's
show one more thing that I think is
cool.
We can maybe just talk about. We don't
need to show just because of time about
the SQL store.
And then I believe you've got a couple
of your own examples that you're just gonna
quickly run this through as well to show
Yeah. What can be done. So the one
thing that I really enjoy that I also
want to show and maybe we can cause
an error here as well. I think we
got about twenty minutes left. So as the
webhook,
I think this is really, really cool.
Been able to integrate with GitHub for their
push events for the API or GitLab or
any other sources or even the Slack API.
I don't know if they still do that,
but they're going by Pipedreams are really cool.
Where Pipedream just gives me this URL that
I can pass around
anywhere I want and then get the payslot
back to here as well. Right. We don't
we don't need to do anything from this.
I just think it's a really one of
the really cool triggers that I like to
play with as well. Yeah. Yeah. We I
mean, we use it all the time for
internal workflows.
And, you know, like you said, it's like
we we've tried to build up
event sources to abstract
webhook delivery from a lot of apps. So
for GitHub,
you know, we're actually creating a webhook subscription
in your repo
that points to an endpoint behind the scenes
so that you don't have to set up
any of this. But, of course, we don't
have full coverage of event sources for every
app. So anytime you have
a custom app that supports webhooks,
like you said, you can go in here.
This endpoint's unique to your workflow. You just
copy it and paste it in the webhook
settings,
and you're getting events here.
And this is more you know, we we
didn't look at the event data much before
for cron because it wasn't that interesting. But
this test event, you can see how
there's a couple things here I'll mention. When
we receive, for example, JSON data in the
incoming payload,
we parse it as a JavaScript object,
and that's what you see in body.
So, you know, we do and multipart form
data,
other data, we think pretty hard about, like,
what are the most common formats and how
do you wanna consume those within a workflow.
A JavaScript object is often the easiest mechanism.
So, again, you send JSON,
you get it as an object in steps
dot triggered on event dot body.
And then you can inspect it just like
you you have before. So, yeah, the HTTP
trigger is pretty cool. We've got an email
trigger as well.
If you quit out of this and then
select
the email trigger,
Also,
unique email address
specific to your workflow.
So you can send any emails here with
attachments,
and
those will actually get
get rendered in the event inspector so you
can parse an email data or handle attachments
in that way.
Oh, cool. I actually didn't know about that
one. That one's quite handy, actually. I can
think of a few things I'd like to
get out of my inbox and then to
some sort of automations. Yeah.
I'm a big I before
well, in in between BrightRoll, you know, I
worked with this team for a long time
at BrightRoll. In between BrightRoll and Pipedream, I
founded a company called Mail Coach where we
did a lot with programmatic
filter creation in Gmail.
So trying to really help cut down on
email volume for people. I wish I had
Pipedream at that point because there's a lot
of automations that I I wish I could
have done,
you know, where you have a user who's
trying to, you know, process some email. We're
trying to create a filter off of it.
There's just so many automations with email that
I think you can do that are interesting.
And, yeah, programmatic filter creation with Gmail is
a big one on my mind because I
try to get as much email out of
my inbox as possible too.
And what about the the SDK? Do wanna
give us a little bit of information on
this? Yeah. The the SDK is you can
see example notes snippets and Ruby snippets. So
we we publish
yeah. Actually, sorry, three clients. There's the JavaScript
browser
version that you can load on a on
a front end app. There's the node version,
and then there's the Ruby SDK. And so
if you're sending events
from,
you know, whatever
client browser or server side service you want,
you can
trigger an event in this way. Right? So
the relevant code is the very bottom.
Once you've,
you know, got the PD SDK, you can
just send event to
that endpoint ID with whatever shape you want.
Now this shape is, pretty custom.
And so,
essentially,
you know, before with HTTP and email, we
saw
steps dot trigger dot event dot body, for
example, because the body
is you know, represents the payload in the
HTTP context.
With the SDK,
you can fully control the shape of the
event that you wanna come in, and it
helps to simplify things. And, again, if you're
sending data server side from an app you
own and then you wanna trigger a Pipedream
workflow off of that, the SDK is often
a a pretty easy option
because you get a lot more control over
that incoming event shape.
Have you ever had anyone tried to build
their own Google Analytics using this?
Not that I know of.
That's a really good use case, though. I
mean, I I could you know, we have
people sending data to Google Analytics
and Amplitude and and other services.
But I mean, I I could envision just
a lot you could do here with that.
I've
been trying to remove well, I have removed
Google Analytics from my from my own website.
I'm trying to use things that are a
bit more privacy focused and Mhmm. Doing something
like this is actually probably a pretty good
step towards getting better at that. Totally. Totally.
Alright. Let's see what else did we not
cover. Yeah. We can do it right People
will probably take just five minutes to cover
if you if you wanna do that. I
can show you how that works.
So Yeah.
This is actually good because since you don't
have any tables, you see the default experience
here. We
walk you through just a basic tutorial, but
I'll I'll walk everyone through this now.
The SQL service
is
essentially
like, we we thought a lot about
what is the use case for me wanting
to query analytics data that I get in
a workflow. Like, it's very common that I
receive data from a webhook from,
for example, Stripe
or SendGrid.
And I wanna run some basic analytics on
that to look at how many unsubscribes
or clicks we got for a given SendGrid
campaign, for example.
As a data scientist, like, I don't wanna
do all the work to manage my data
warehouse for all these workflows that are often
just one offs. Like, if it's not core
data and I just wanna really quickly run
some SQL
on incoming data from a webhook or some
source. The SQL service is kind of our
intent at, like, getting to the simplest possible
way to do that. So the idea is
you just send JSON
to a table.
We actually create
the table schema behind the scenes and manage
that for you. So every user essentially has
their own database,
and you can create any number of tables
in the SQL service simply just by sending
JSON data to a table with a specific
name.
We create the table with that schema.
If you send new data with a new
schema to that same table, we adjust the
schema over time.
So it's essentially a dynamic schema managed for
each of your tables, And, again, it's all
hosted.
It's free to use,
and we the only restriction is that we
expire all the data after thirty days automatically.
But, for for common use cases where, again,
I just need to get some insight. Like,
that I'm a data guy. Right? So I
think of, how can I ask all these
interesting questions of my data? I immediately go
to SQL, but I just don't wanna manage
the database and the schema for all this
data, especially JSON
where the schema can change so much constantly.
Right?
So that's the principle.
Let's see how it works.
If you go to a new workflow
does that all make sense, by the way?
Yeah. Yeah. It does. Cool. Yeah. Cool. I'll
I'll say yes. I'll I'll work at it
as we go here. You
can select any trigger you want and then
add a new Node. Js code step.
So this is where the dollar send function
comes in. We we do actually have an
action for this as well, but I'll show
you the the code because it's a little
bit easier. Dollar send dot SQL.
And that accepts
a JavaScript object as an argument. So
with two properties,
table.
You can enter whatever name you want here.
K. Sure.
And then payload.
And payload itself accepts a JavaScript object, and
so put in whatever fields you want here.
Awesome.
But people will believe me if I have
anyone.
Yeah. Yeah.
Go ahead and deploy that
and run a test event.
And so
we with destinations like this, we we actually
batch
all the incoming events
that you would send within a sixty second
period
and then send those to the SQL service
for processing. So it does take just a
little bit of time the first time you
create a table.
But the idea is, you know, you have
thousands of events coming at the same time.
We're dispatching all those and delivering those once
a minute to the SQL service.
But if you go back to the SQL
tab,
we can
just, again, wait a second and refresh this.
But pretty soon, the table's gonna show up
on the left,
and then we can
start querying. If you go back to your
workflow, you can also check on the status
of the execution.
So we do when we deliver the event,
if you click on that event on the
left
and you check oh, there we go. So
we should be good now.
Oh,
it it takes just a little longer, so
there's a lot going on behind the scenes.
So let's fingers crossed. We've we've had luck
in this demo so far.
What database is actually running behind the scenes?
Yeah. We we use Amazon Athena.
And so all the data's in s three,
and then we create
we use Athena as the query engine. AWS
Glue
manages the schema.
So Athena can inherit Glue. I didn't know
anything about Glue before I used it for
this. But,
essentially, Glue manages your schema. So you see
the schema there, name and age. And if
you just select star from Rawkode,
you should get your data.
There you go.
So, yeah, you can, you know, Athena's pretty
powerful as a query engine.
You know, supports
window functions, all the kind of advanced capabilities
you'd expect out of a a legitimate database.
And so,
again, if you have any questions you wanna
ask, you know, really quickly of your data
and you don't wanna manage data warehouse, this
is a good option.
Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. Thank you for that. That's just that
is the first time I played with
SQL SQL
stuff. So that was cool to see.
Awesome.
I guess,
yeah, we kinda covered quite a lot there.
So why don't we do you wanna run
through some of your
your own use cases then? Sure. Yeah. I'll
I'll briefly you know, I had a couple
more slides to show some example work I'll
share my screen again, and I'll show you
a couple that we run internally that are
a little more advanced.
And these are all linked
from
from here.
So later on, if you wanna take a
look, they're all public.
I'll start off with a a little more
advanced one. I won't go over all of
this code, but I'll talk about the use
case.
So we run Kubernetes
internally,
and we have a for those of you
who are familiar with Kubernetes,
we have a public node group.
So Kubernetes,
you know, lets us manage a ton of
different services really easily. You love it.
We have this public node group that's responsible
for some public facing services, including destination delivery,
actually. It's a dollarsend. SQL.
And,
essentially, we have this problem where
I'll I'll briefly just show you since we
have a little bit of time.
Other destination. So all the destinations, all the
dollar send primitives
I showed off, dollarsend.email,
dollar send SQL.
There's one more dollarsend.http
that's
probably the most commonly used.
This allows you to send an HTTP request
from a workflow.
The key
benefit of using the HTTP destination
here
versus using
a a client like Axios
or, Gott that you might typically be familiar
with in JavaScript.
The benefit of using this over those is
these HTTP requests are actually handled asynchronously.
And so when you run dollarsend dot HTTP,
if you have thousands of HTTP requests you
wanna send, you're actually not charged for the
compute time
of waiting for the response from the server,
you know, which can take maybe two to
three hundred milliseconds for some services, right, or
even longer. So
given that you're capped on compute time in
the free tier,
you
wanna manage that, especially for high volume workflows.
Dollar send out HTTP
lets you send, you know, again, any number
of HTTP requests. We send the HTTP request
behind the scenes,
asynchronously
outside of your workflow.
So, there's a lot going on there. The
point is it saves you a ton of
compute time if you're making a lot of
HTTP requests.
Now
one of the first questions we got was,
well, I need to white list Pipedream's IPs
so I can send data to services that
I own or services that require an IP
white list.
These are our list of IPs. Now
when we add we're constantly adding
new nodes that handle this traffic
in our Kubernetes cluster. So one of the
issues we ran across was we have this
static list of IPs that we don't wanna
change.
We need to keep those that list, you
know, again, fairly static for users,
but we get new nodes. How do we
assign
static IPs to those nodes automatically?
Well, we have a Pipedream workflow handle this.
When a new node comes online
in our public node group,
we get an event from AWS
that comes into you can't see it because
this is the public version, but in my
copy of the workflow,
I have the HTTP endpoint that David showed
off a few minutes ago. So AWS events
trigger this workflow.
And then, again, I won't go over this
code, but there's a lot of stuff here
that,
we've done to basically handle that event,
get the node group, and then use the
AWS API
to assign
one of
our pool of IPs
to that new node.
So pretty narrow problem, but, you know, we
realized,
okay. I just wanna listen for new nodes,
and I wanna assign an IP address to
that node when it comes online.
So a Pipedream workflow was perfect because it's
just an event driven asynchronous workflow.
So you can take a look at that
a little more. But I just wanted to
kinda show you that, you know, we use
Pipedream a lot internally
for our own workflows for some pretty hefty
production use cases.
So I know we've been going over Discord
and Twitter and, you know, Pipedream is fantastic
for those use cases, but it it does
really help glue together a lot of AWS
services and and other services as well. So
that's why I like that example.
Have another DevOps. See, I know your audience,
you know, loves Kubernetes and ops stuff. So
I'll show you one more here.
SSL Mate is this great API. I think
they operate a specific API, sorry, called cert
spotter
that lets you,
basically find certificates,
given a bunch of criteria. So domain is
the main criteria. You can basically list all
the SSL certs
that have been published for a domain. We
wanna make sure that no certs are published
for any domains we own that we don't
know about.
Now that's just a common security thing that
some,
that's bitten some companies in the past where
someone actually creates an SSL cert for a
domain that they don't own. So we wanna
get
new domains
sent sorry. New certs
sent to us anytime we get
a a new cert spotted on the web.
So you just list your domains here for
Pipedream.com,
for example.
This hits the search spotter API.
This runs on a cron schedule so that
every few minutes, it's checking for new certs.
And then it just
down here, I use dollar send dot email
to email me any new certs.
We haven't talked too much about dollar checkpoint,
but dollar checkpoint is
it gives you it's a variable that gives
you access to the built in key value
store for workflows.
So I'll briefly just show you those docs.
Let me search
flow state.
But anytime you need to save data in
a workflow and retrieve it in a future
execution,
Workflow state using the variable dollar checkpoint
lets you do that. There's also step level
state.
So this dot dollar checkpoint allows you to
save data
within a specific step and reference that data
later.
These docs are extensive and have a lot
of examples, but briefly,
you know, we need to keep track of
any certificates we've seen previously
in previous executions of the workflow.
And then I only wanna get notified of
new certificates.
So cert spotter lists all the certificates in
the workflow. I keep track of the ones
I've seen so far.
And any new certificates that come in, I
only email those.
And I say, new cert found for domains.
Okay?
So those are couple, examples. I I linked
to a lot of other blogs, including some
from,
Raymond Camden, who, is a developer advocate at
here
and, blogs about us a lot. He uses
Pipedream for some demos internally. Internally. He's got
a couple great blog posts here.
I wrote up a blog post about how
I used Pipedream to avoid parking tickets
in San Francisco. That's a pretty fun one
and utilizes some APIs that the San Francisco
the city of San Francisco provides on street
cleaning schedules.
So there's just a lot of examples here
that I thought you know, a variety that
I thought might be helpful for people new
to Pipedream.
The, other thing I wanted to mention was,
you know, all of our code is on
GitHub. Okay? I'll look at this repo really
quickly.
This repo contains all the code for primarily
our event sources. We're planning to add our
actions to GitHub soon as well so people
can submit PRs against those. So all the,
like, Spotify and Twitter actions David used today,
those are gonna be in GitHub, hopefully pretty
soon. Our docs are also here. So a
lot of good stuff here if you wanna
consume Pipedream content and kinda see what we're
open sourcing.
We also run a a big Slack community.
So any questions you have, we're more than
happy
to answer them. We use GitHub discussions and
Slack both as our help channels.
And then just a bunch of docs and
resources that I thought would be helpful. So
as you dive into Pipedream, these are all
good places to start to understand
more about the concepts we talked about. But
I'll let you peruse those in your own
time.
Yeah.
I'll make sure there's a link to those
slides
and the show notes so people can hopefully
get a link to that and then trace
all those additional resources.
I feel like we we we covered an
awful lot. I
hope that people that are watching are you
know, your interest has peaked and you're signing
up for a Pipedream account now. The
free tier is ridiculously generous. I've gotta say,
like, I don't think anyone's gonna run into
any issues getting started with Pipedream there.
So
there was one thing that popped into my
head there just as we were wrapping up.
So I'm curious about you said you were
gonna make the potentially make the actions available
on github.com.
Yes. Would I be able to have my
own actions repo and pointpipedream.com
to it eventually? Yeah. We we envision you
know,
the the one of the biggest points of
feedback we heard and actually the top issue
on our GitHub repo by upvotes is I
wanna serialize workflows
as code,
hack on workflows locally, keep workflow code in
my own Git repo. Actions would be the
same. We we envision
you know, we're not there yet. Right? But
the vision is that you should be able
to manage Pipedream workflows like you manage any
code.
So both with workflows and
actions, even private actions you haven't published,
those ideally would live in your own repos.
Public actions that we publish, we wanna contribute.
You know, you could put those in the
Pipedream GitHub repo just like our public event
sources are.
But if you look at the event source
documentation, that that's kinda where we're headed. So
event sources,
those are in GitHub.
You can keep your own event sources in
your own repo private, manage those programmatically via
the CLI and API.
So all the docs are on event sources.
That's essentially the same vision we wanna apply
to workflows and actions.
Everything can be serialized to code. Everything can
be kept in Git.
Nice. Awesome. Yeah.
Alright. Well, thank you for joining me today.
That was really insightful.
I actually learned quite a lot, which was
really good. And I think we covered I
can't believe we never had any errors. I'm
actually surprised at myself for that. But Yeah.
Good job. I know. That's not how my
normal Pipedream day to day goes. So I
make a lot of bugs. But thank you
again for taking the time out of your
day, for joining us today, showing us Pipedream,
and
have a great day. Thank you again. Thank
you. Thank you for having me, David. My
pleasure. Thank you. Bye.